[Music]
in the previous videos we saw what
compound statements are and how to check
their validity now let's see what
conditional statements are if you watch
this video carefully then you will
definitely understand this topic wait
what did I just say okay let me write it
for you I said if you watch this video
carefully then you will definitely
understand this topic so what am I doing
here I'm talking about a condition and a
respective outcome so what are such
statements involving an if condition and
an outcome fault yes such statements are
called conditional statements now in
this statement can you tell me what the
condition is yes it's if you watch this
video carefully and what's the outcome
yes you will definitely understand this
topic let's denote the statement as P
and this one is Q so can you tell me now
how can we represent a conditional
statement yes we can represent it as if
P then Q where P is the condition and Q
is the outcome now I want you to be a
little more attentive here in this
statement if P occurs then what will be
its implication the implication of
occurrence of P would bathe the
occurrence of Q so can we say that Q is
nothing but the implication of P that is
the occurrence of P implies the
occurrence of Q so we can write this as
P implies Q mathematically we can also
write it as this which is read as P
implies Q which means that if P happens
then Q will definitely happen that is if
P then Q okay now that we know what a
conditional statement is can we think of
a few more examples
here's the first one if I study will
then I will pass and how about this if a
player commits a foul then she is
penalized simple isn't it
do share with us the examples you came
up with now let me tell you that the
conditional statements may also be of
the form B only if Q or P if and only if
Q but we will see them in the videos to
come for now let's see what converse
statements are we just saw what if then
conditional statements are that is
statements of the form if P then Q now
can you tell me for this statement if Q
then P is also true that is whether the
converse of the statement is also true
yes for a statement of the form if P
then Q its converse statement would be
if Q then P that is Q implies P it's
nothing but interchanging conditions and
the outcome simply put it means that if
Q happens then P also happens now let's
see whether the converse statement is
also true let's find out consider the
first example again if you watch this
video carefully then you will understand
this topic now what would Q implies P or
the converse for this statement P yes
the converse would be if I understood
this topic then I watch the video
carefully but is this true
I'm afraid not and why do I say so let's
understand by watching the video
carefully you will definitely understand
this topic but that is just one way of
doing it you may understand this topic
by watching other videos or from some
book or from any other source
but need not be this video necessarily
does we can say that for the statement P
implies Q the converse of the statement
that is Q implies P need not be true
let's take one more example for clarity
considered this statement if Renaldo
plays well then Juventus will win what
would be the converse of this statement
yes it would be if you Ventus won then
Rinaldo played well can you tell me
whether the converse of this statement
has to be true of course not
let's understand why Rinaldo playing
well is one of the sufficient conditions
for un tiss to win
that is if Rinaldo plays well the new
ventus will win regardless of the other
conditions but does that mean it's the
only condition for Juventus to win right
it isn't the only condition Aventis may
also win because of the other players
performing well or the opponent's not
playing well or some other reason even
though Rinaldo may not play well so
again we see that for the statement P
implies Q we cannot say that q also
implies P that is converse need not be
true so now we know what an if-then
statement is and also it's converse in
our next video we will see what inverse
and contrapositive statements are
[Music]
you